and actually would love to do this
transition um do you have any advice or
maybe also just Reflections on your
journey to share what people can do I
think coming from an engineering
background is a big plus point in the
tech sector because at the end of the
day you are working with software
engineers and having that engineering
background being able to empathize with
the realities of building anything
probably in a relatively strong position
but also like the rise of B2B software
company companies having a specific
industry background and bringing that
knowledge of the construction sector
which I had into a tech company helped
us build new tech products for the
construction sector and so yeah in a way
it can actually be a golden ticket to
get in